was killed the Israeli government began
circulating this video it shows an armed
Palestinian firing his weapon Israel
says it shows how the veteran Al Jazeera
correspondent was likely shot by
Palestinian gunfire and not by its
forces but that's disputed by rights
groups Witnesses and journalists who've
analyzed the video Israel says this is
where the Palestinian fighter opened
fire from this point jerusalem-based
human rights organization selum says
there are too many walls alleys and
buildings blocking the site where
Shireen was shot and GPS verification
and dozens of video clips shows this is
where Israeli soldiers were located as
they raided a home in Janine it shows a
direct line of fire to where Shireen was
shot and killed the site is also far
from the Palestinian resistance fighter
who was about 260 meters away
God selum says Israel's version of
events is based on a false narrative
designed to protect the perpetrators
there is no line of sight between one
location and the other and in fact our
researcher it has taken him a few
minutes to walk from one location to the
other location the announcement on
Investigation is one of Israel's most
tried and unfortunately successful
tricks and blanket impunity that Ezra
provides itself a witness says Israeli
forces were not under attack
when the journalists arrived they were
surprised because the occupation forces
were closing the street with their
military vehicles and then they started
shooting at them a man tried once again
to retrieve shireen's body we were not
aware at that point that she had been
killed he tried to provide first aid to
her so they started shooting at him and
the bullets hit a tree over his head the
guys here were not throwing stones nor
shooting there was no form of resistance
he
the European Union has called for an
independent investigation into her death
and the U.S Envoy to the U.N has called
for shireen's killing to be
transparently investigated
but Israel has a track record of not
punishing its soldiers who have
committed crimes against Palestinians
and it's never jailed one of its
soldiers for the killing of a journalist
katsia Lopez Al Jazeera with me in the
studio now is Abdullah al-arian he is an
associate professor of history at
Georgetown University here in Qatar
thank you for coming into the studio
um people as we've been saying people
have grown up watching Serene cover
these these huge events in the history
of Palestine and the Palestinians
struggle how important is that the
witnessing of this I mean I think her
contribution has been absolutely immense
uh you know not to to kind of overstress
the point but she's been covering these
events going back decades to the point
that she's brought the Palestinian
struggle uh into the lives of millions
and millions of people worldwide
especially given that this was really
the first truly Global News Network that
was uh showing things from the
perspective of people living there on
the ground I think it's also important
to keep in mind that Not only was she
covering the obvious uh you know the
wars the the frequent assaults on Gaza
on people in the West Bank but she's
she's there covering the daily attacks
on people she's covering the daily
struggles with ethnic cleansing with the
the expansion of settlements over the
last two decades when we consider the
fact that ever since the Oslo process
began settlements have more than tripled
in the West Bank and so those kinds of
daily affronts to the idea of
Palestinians being able to exercise any
sort of sovereignty on their own land
has been covered tremendously by by
shittin throughout this entire period
reminder audience of what the ozone
processes because we've had a few
different correspondents talking about
it before it's a bit you're a professor
of History so just lay that out for us
sure I mean this is this is the process
that began in the early 1990s when there
was the possibility that there could be
a two-state resolution
um to the competing claims over
historical Palestine and yet what we've
seen of course since then is that all
that the Oslo process allowed is for the
Palestinians essentially to abandon any
sense of attempting to struggle for
their Liberation and at the same time
permitting Israel to continue to expand
its its ethnic cleansing of Palestine
and again this is a process that began
going back to 1948 when the state of
Israel was established at the expense of
three quarters of a million Palestinians
who were made refugees overnight and of
course the remainder of the residents
there became either citizens of Israel
that received second-class citizen
treatment or in the case of Palestinians
in the West Bank and Gaza who have are
actually stateless but exist under a
state of permanent military occupation
and continuous colonialism
let's zoom out for a minute and and just
explain to us how it is that this has
been allowed to continue for 70 years
because you have I know they're not a
direct comparison but you have Russia
invading Ukraine and you have the Glo
the West is
resounding in its condemnation and this
must end quickly and we will do
everything we can
how is it that an occupation like this
has been allowed to continue for so long
well I think it is in part the
responsibility of Western Powers who
first going all the way back to the
British occupation and colonization of
Palestine who permitted for the
emergence of a settler Colonial movement
that was European in its Origins to
solve a number of the the problems in
the forces of kind of discrimination and
genocide that were taking place in
Europe going back to the 19th and 20th
centuries and at the same time happening
at the expense of the indigenous
population and so we've seen a kind of
emergence of a settler Colonial entity
similar to what we've seen for instance
in South Africa under apartheid of
course we've seen now the overwhelming
majority of Human Rights organizations
around the world have have all come to
the conclusion of what Palestinians have
been saying for decades which of course
is the fact that Israel is exercising an
apartheid type control over the lives of
Palestinians both within the state of
Israel and also within the occupied
territories there's been no political
will on the part of the International
Community as we know it whether it's the
United Nations whether it's the US
European allies to try and end this this
situation in any kind of meaningful or
just way
our very uh shortly expecting the
arrival of the uh the body of serene
abuaklay these are live pictures
obviously there's a lot of people there
so excuse our camera uh they're getting
a steady shot you can see
there are the procession coming in
is very arguments
sorry
they're carrying their funeral they're
carrying the coffin high on their arms
uh I believe we have Steph
Anie Decker Steph if you can hear us and
if you're in a place to do so
body down
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
so they're trying to lay a wreath down
onto the coffin
thank you
[Music]
there's a lot of emotion here
what they're basically doing now is
carrying her coffin let's go into the
board
they're trying to open the way basically
this is I think what you're witnessing
here is emotion also on part of the
journalists
for them it's also incredibly personal
um people are very emotional here which
is why they're trying the hospital staff
are trying to get people to um to give
space but uh but it's been very
difficult so I think now they're going
to try and
just carry the coffin
and give it so because what they wanted
to do put it down on the bed for 10 or
15 minutes to have people
pay their respects
just letting you take in some of these
sins
basically
um
they're saying rest in peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
throwing rose petals on her coffin
[Music]
Unity Palestine
a lot of emotions
[Music]
so basically her coffee now being taken
into the board
is
[Applause]
sorry so
[Applause]
um
because you can see just the the
heightened motions the chaos that the
situation was they've now put her into
this gentleman having a rose that were
handed out to put on the coffin we are
just trying to get some space now she's
been laid into the Moor which is where
the body will stay
until tomorrow
[Music]
this is javada one of the Al Jazeera
Arabic correspondents
so
um incredibly it's it's incredibly even
even submit crying uh very difficult to
see this
um now that she's arrived here
and everyone it's hard to keep your
emotions together it's um she just went
to work like everyone does
um
and didn't expect to come home like
yesterday we were watching her um her
body come back to Ramallah to the office
nobody expected in the morning when she
sent an email at 6 30 like everybody
does
that she was going to track uh on the
situation in June on her age to be
brought back you know uh dead and having
her colleagues inconsolable around her
so this is you know this is the this is
I think you've got sadness here there's
going to be a lot of anger there is
anger
um and I think people will tell you that
you know accountability and Justice is
very difficult uh under these
circumstances under the Israeli
occupation she's not the first she is
the most high profile
um it's uh yeah it's it's very difficult
all right Steph hey thank you so much
for that
Stephanie Decker with our team there
in occupied East Jerusalem we're the
body of Shireen has just been taken
let's come back to the studio now where
we have Abdullah al-arian associate
professor of history at Georgetown
University in Qatar obviously hugely
emotional scenes there but as we've been
saying not surprising given I guess the
the depth of her contribution to
journalism and to the Arab world
yeah absolutely I think you know it's
it's really important to see the kinds
of impact that shedding light on these
on these abuses and these daily
atrocities can have and I think you know
one of the things that we heard
yesterday from it is really military
spokesperson is he said you know they're
armed with cameras right so this is kind
of interesting to think about the way
that they juxtapose the work of
journalists who are just there to kind
of shed light and try to bring a certain
reality to people that often gets
covered or or overlooked it says a lot
doesn't it armed with cameras absolutely
I think it really speaks to the fact
that these are targeted killings and I
think we've seen enough evidence of that
in fact in 2019 a U.N commission
concluded that Israel was intentionally
targeting journalists and we've seen
that this is not an isolated incident
this has occurred dozens of times over
the last 20 years we can point to
incidents in which journalists were
killed in you know in the duty of trying
to report on what's happening in Israel
and in Palestine yeah I know that the uh
the International Federation
is killing is part of a deliberate
systematic targeting of journalists and
like Steph was saying you know she was
just going to work she was going to do
her job which is very passionate about
spreading shedding light on on an
occupation and everything that that
entails for the people of Palestine
doing her job and a job which is
necessary for for the world to know what
is happening what does history tell us
about how
Israel is likely to respond whether
there is likely to be any any justice
well history tells us otherwise
certainly that that in the course of all
of the previous incidents similar to
this one that there's never been any
kind of accountability that normally
what these investigations do is they
they ultimately turn into cover-ups
attempts to basically say that that
there was no responsibility I mean we've
already seen that process begin right
we've seen the denials we've seen the
recriminations we've seen issuing of
videos that have absolutely no relevance
whatsoever to the uh to the killing in
question we've already seen the kinds of
of types of responses that we can invest
from any sort of investigation and not
to mention the fact that these are never
isolated incidents in the sense that
it's just simply one person acting but
rather we've seen that there's
structural violence involved in the way
that the occupation itself functions and
So within that context it's impossible
to ever assume that there can be any
kind of a uh you know an objective or
transparent investigation and so the
only real solution to that is to have an
international body of some kind that can
actually conduct that investigation and
then hold Israel to account for its
actions and and I guess the reporting of
that structural violence was something
that Shireen did because as we've been
saying you know among her many
assignments were the big things covering
five Wars in Gaza Israel's war with
Lebanon you know home evictions the
killings of Palestinian youth for
detention of Palestinian youth the
illegal Israeli settlements which are
continuing to expand but also those
daily things those daily raids the
impact on on people when they're
displaced so I guess my question is you
know how important is it that those
stories are told too
yeah absolutely because I think this is
one of the problems in terms of the way
that the the media gaze shift its focus
really to the kind of the hot spots and
the moments where things are are really
heating up in a specific place and kind
of tend to ignore the daily uh instances
of violence and the way that for
instance the ethnic cleansing that's
occurring within Palestine happens in
ways that are much more mundane and not
as as kind of camera friendly so to
speak so just to give you an example
just this past week an Israeli High
Court ruled for the eviction of eight
Palestinian Villages right so these are
the kinds of things that happen the home
demolitions things that oftentimes don't
get covered in the same way that that
the military uh you know the all-out
military assaults do get covered I think
much more directly but even on the media
question I mean going back to this
question of Investigations we know that
last summer the Israeli Air Force bombed
uh military building or sorry rather a
media building in in Gaza that have that
housed the Associated Press in Al
Jazeera and to this day we still don't
have any kind of accountability for that
so so I don't think that we can
necessarily expect the same for this
incident
um
but one I think is important for our
International viewers who may not
um
you know be intimately familiar with
what we mean when we say life under
occupation what we mean when we say
covering
um you know covering the impacts of an
occupation so just for for our
International audience can you explain
to us what what we mean by that
yeah what we've been is is a system in
which the the structures of power don't
represent you as a person right so the
Palestinians don't have any kind of
Rights or claims under a military
occupation they're simply at the mercy
of an occupying force that has been
there at least in the case of the West
Bank and Gaza since 1967. that controls
every element of their daily life from
movement from what economic
opportunities they might have from
access to Medical Care we've seen for
instance on people die at border
crossings because they're unable to
access medical care while they're going
to try at the checkpoints rather and so
these are the kinds of things that exist
the daily humiliations of soldiers that
are able to rate homes that are able to
also um to to seize homes to demolish
them and there's no recourse right
there's no court system from which
people can actually claim any sort of
relief because ultimately this is a
discriminatory system that exists to
privilege one population at the EXT at
the expense of another I mean again this
is why the international human rights
Community has reached this consensus in
the last few years to basically say this
is very much akin to what we saw in
apartheid in South Africa there's some
obvious important differences but the
idea of keeping people separate and
discriminating between them on the basis
of their ethnicity or their religious
background or ethnic background is very
much present I mean we've seen it even
just over the last month with the
assaults on the holy sites in Jerusalem
right that those daily provocations were
very much kind of again intended to
remove Palestinian Muslim and Christian
rights in Jerusalem which I guess is
also one of the reasons why reporting
from the ground is is so important
shining a light on on all of these daily
provocations these daily humiliations
hey thank you very much for your time we
appreciate it Abdullah and there an
associate professor of history at
Georgetown University